mein name ist luca um meine lieben
zuschauer vor vielen jahren habe ich
dieses video hier auf meinem kanal
hochgeladen
das war ein video in dem ich euch
gezeigt habe wie man in minecraft in
unter fünf minuten in seiner ersten
diamanten findet und es war zudem auch
mein erstes richtiges youtube video und
ihr seht bereits im titel eingeblendet
dieses video stelle ich heute nach
bzw ich stelle es nicht richtig eins zu
eins nach sondern ich schaue mir das
video an
stück für stück und versuche die tipps
die lokale gibt selbst zu befolgen
hey leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal vier in einer zufällig
generierten welt in minecraft aber wer
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet
ja das war tatsächlich meine stimme
früher
wir müssen halt überlegen dass ich da
irgendwie 15 jahre alt war oder so aber
gut luca hat auf jeden fall jeden
geklickt und was muss ich als nächstes
machen luca dafür erstelle ich mir mal
eben eine neue welt wie ihr gesehen habt
habe ich keinen ziel eingegeben das ist
einfach aus dem grund damit ihr nicht
vorwerfen können hey der harten zeit
genommen den hat er vorher schon mal
benutzt hat da vorher schon geguckt oder
diamanten sind alles klar luca okay also
ich nicke auf neue welt erstellen
nämlich nennen die welt einfach mal
erstes video und ich wähle keinen zieht
aus also klickt einfach auf neue welt
erstellen damit ihnen nicht sagen wie
sie verwendet was ich als erstes mache
ist was ich mir holzholen okay also luca
hat sich als erstes holz geholt das
heißt ich gehe auch hier als erstes hin
und bauen ein bisschen holz ab die frage
ist wie viel holz sich eigentlich
brauche dabei ist es egal welches als
das ist das kann diese reiche hier sein
das kann auch dieses braune haut sein
das ist komplett egal
dann habe ich aber nicht gefragt ich
wollte wissen wie viel holz ich brauche
luca ihr könnt euch vier holz holen es
wäre aber besser wenn ihr euch fünf holz
holt das ist einfach sicherer wenn ihr
nachher noch mehr sticks braucht okay
also drei holz habe ich schon jetzt das
vierte und vorne das fünfte also dann
geben einfach mal den sicheren weg das
krasses auf minecraft sieht jetzt anders
aus ich meine schaut euch das hier an
das ist alles so wunderschön geworden
und aber gut höre weiter mit dem
früheren video ihr macht euch erstmal
eine workbench und zwölf stocker denn
die brauchen wir nachher also ab ins
inventar gehen und erst mal hier die
sachen zu den stämmen machen daraus
machen wir uns dann eine workbench die
haben wir hier und zwölf stücke also
luca also zwölf stücke haben jetzt auch
am start work bench setzt sich jetzt
einfach mal irgendwo absetzen einfach
hier ab und ich mache mir jetzt eine
stein schaufel und eine stein spitzhacke
also die workbench irgendwo abstellen
die stelle ich einfach mal hier an den
see und jetzt eine stein schaufel und
eine spitzhacke das heißt so zac und wir
haben hier einmal eine und noch dass wir
so auf dem guten weg und jetzt liegt es
an euch ihr könnt euch jetzt irgendeinen
ort in eurer minecraft welt suchen
irgendein ort gar nicht mehr suchen an
dem ihr euch einfach eine erde graben
wollte ich könnte mich natürlich jetzt
auch schon hier in der erde graben oder
hier oder hier oder auch hier bleibe ich
auch irgendwo runter lukat vollidiot
also gut dann laufen wir hier jetzt mal
einfach irgendwo rum
das ding ist wir sind halt eigentlich
sogar relativ schön bunt hier sind
überall so schöne bäumchen wir sind
überall so kleine seen hiervon ist auch
noch ein sehe ich meine also wirklich
schaut euch das mal hier bei diesen
gemeinschaft ist so ein wunderschönes
spiel wichtig dieser welt einfach nicht
danach aus dass hier drunter
höhlensystem jetzt sind daher in der
nähe keine berge sind also wenn ihr
gesehen habt euch am besten neben einem
berg in den boden das ist immer an sich
ist ja berge sind jetzt nicht so
unbedingt vorhanden aber ich gehe erst
mal von diesem baum hier wieder runter
dass ihr vor das glaubst du der höchste
berg im ganzen umkreis das heißt neben
einem berg soll man sich untergraben
hier vorne ist es eigentlich direkt
neben dem berg so hier sieht auch gut
aus in dem us werk ist es schon
tieferlegen ich grad nicht einfach mal
hier runter okay also dann wäre ich
jetzt meine holz schaufel aus und gerade
mich jetzt hier einfach nach unten als
bin ich bei spanien gekommen
das heißt ich euch fortschritt oder hole
ich noch ein paar steine hier damit ich
mir bessere werkzeuge machen kann ok
also wir sollten uns jetzt erstmal noch
ein paar steinchen holen damit wir uns
bessere werkzeuge machen können einem
das ding ist wir haben ja auch direkt
eisen gefunden
das ist auch gut weil damit kann man
dann nachher den diamanten abbauen dafür
jetzt mal einfach erzählt eben unter mir
und mache mir die gleichen sachen wie am
anfang nur noch mal entscheiden ich
mache mir dann erstmal hier eine stein
spitzhacke und dann mache ich mir noch
eine schaufel eben genau die partie hier
vorne hin und ich mache mir auch noch
eben einen stein schwert wenn ich jetzt
schon die ganzen sachen habe falls
irgendwelche zombies ankommen sollten
und damit kann ich jetzt sogar hier das
eisen abbauen das machen wir natürlich
gerade nicht alles so auf zeit wie ich
das damals gemacht habe da ich wirklich
zeit gestoppt waren fünf minuten und
dann hatte ich sogar das glück dass ich
direkt diamanten gefunden habe sondern
wir bauen uns jetzt einfach ja wir
machen just for fun arbeite ich das
überhaupt weiter vorgehen ich hab mich
nämlich zwei blöcke immer runter weil
wenn ihr euch nur einen block runter
kraft wissen nicht was unter euch ist
deswegen kann es sein dass zwischendurch
nur einfach aber sie kommt
ich habe jetzt einfach mal so lang unter
30 kohl oder kohle haben wir direkt hier
gefunden das ist auch relativ schön weil
es gerade schon langsam dunkel wird das
heißt wir jetzt unsere sticks packen die
die kohle drauf können uns die fackeln
und können jetzt war er ist natürlich
sinnvoll wenn ich das direkt auf die
kohle setzte also das ist natürlich sehr
gut wenn ihr direkt pole findet ist den
ich unbedingt findet man bestimmt auch
noch unten aber ist natürlich gut wenn
jetzt findet nehmen wir natürlich auch
alles mit brauchen wir später okay also
der 15 jahre alte luca meint auf jeden
fall wir sollen hier alles an kohle
mitnehmen was wir irgendwie haben das
ding ist wir haben hier wirklich
unfassbar viel kohle gerade gefunden
richtigen strang aber vielleicht ist ja
wirklich sinnvoll kann nachher wenn
wegen die fackeln brauchen in der höhle
sind und so weiter und so fort ich bin
tatsächlich auf diese video idee
gekommen von wegen herstellen ein erstes
video nach bzw bevor ich mal deine
eigene anleitung weil mir moritz
geschrieben hatte
ich hatte mir das video angeguckt und
ich dachte das sei so ein crank von dir
gewesen aber das war ja wirklich deine
taktik stimme von früher und er weil er
dann so wertvoll lustig wenn du das mal
nachstellen würde ist aber gut ich freue
mich jetzt weiter herunter oder was habe
ich in dem video damals gesagt wir haben
uns weiter unter und jetzt kommen ein
paar lex warum weiß ich nicht aber egal
ich lass mich dadurch einfach mal nicht
beeindrucken okay also bei luca kamen
alex für ich weiß noch ganz genau ich
habe das auf meinem kleinen alpencup
apple macbook whatever wie das auch hieß
gespielt das ging echt überhaupt nicht
klar aber würde ich komm ich jetzt auf
jeden fall mal weiter voran wie gesagt
ich hoffe einfach dass ich gleich auf
eine höhle stoße bzw aufweisen bzw
direkt schon einen diamanten findet das
halte ich zwar für unrealistisch stadt
diamanten meistens erst auf der höhe
15 beziehungsweise 16 kommen aber ich
bin ja guten mutes alles klappt ist
guten mutes dass wir irgendwie diamanten
finden werden damit ich natürlich
gespannt ob die taktik das muss man halt
auch sagen
das video ist halt irgendwie 78 jahre
alt also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
ganze lief noch funktioniert als die
kraft mich einfach weiter in die tiefe
bis sich auf ein höhlensystem stoße ja
ich hoffe auch dass ich so langsam auf
dem höhlensystem stoßen werden wenn ich
aufhöre 15 bzw 16 bin und auch keine
höhle gefunden habe werde ich mich
einfach in die seite geraden aber
eigentlich stößt
aufhören 15 oder 16 immer auf eine höhle
also laut lukas stößt man auf höhe 15
oder 16 immer auf eine höhle
bisher sehe ich davon noch nicht so viel
ich höre auch noch keine zombies ich
glaube das war mein bier der fall dass
da irgendwie auch ein zombie geräusche
waren lucca daher wusste hey hier ist
eine höhle und da haben doch schon den
ersten 2 gehört das heißt hier direkt
nebenan muss eine höhle sein und da
haben wir auch schon den lover see
gefunden
er findet direkten lover sehen aber wir
haben gerade noch mal kohle gefunden
genau
wir haben allerdings genug kohle und
sind jetzt auf höhe 16 und haben reisen
aber keine diamanten aber wie jüngst in
dem video weiter hab ich verspreche euch
nicht dass ihr klappt was ich hier sage
also das muss nicht unbedingt klappen
[Musik]
dafür wie gut aber ich verspreche euch
nichts also ich hab das muss nicht aber
den knappen wasser auf jeden fall super
gemacht luca die schön aus der
verantwortung geredet frühjahr aber das
hat der 2
das hat damals wirklich geklappt ich
glaube ich weiß ich weiß nicht mehr
genau wie ich den diamanten gefunden hat
aber das können sie auch noch mal eben
kurz anschauen und da haben wir auch
schon den ersten jemanden gefunden
das heißt der keiner stoppt es einfach
mal vier minuten und 59 sekunden
wahnsinn ja was schauen ob ich ja auch
in diamanten finden werde ich bin
allergisch gegen kommissar und das heißt
nämlich in dem video auch dass ich euch
zeige wie man die diamanten findet nicht
wie man sie ab bot er will
jetzt auch noch eine spitzhacke short
gegangen 3
[Musik]
ich höre ja aber auch ich höre hier
irgendwo lava
ihr müsst jetzt bevor er den
diamantenabbau könnt euch noch ein eisen
spitzhacke machen und da sind auch
gleich drei diamanten
reisen spielt sagte mach ich mir
aber du hast drei diamanten und ich habe
bisher suchte
in der nähe muss schon lama sein und das
ist sind safe diamanten schweiz das
geräusch hörte sich so an als wäre hier
irgendwo eine höhle nebenan dreht muss
was sagt luca noch im video also ihr
habt gesehen das geht ziemlich schnell
jemanden zu finden mit diesem trick ja
also wirklich das geht mega schnell mit
diesem trick diamanten zu finden
helmut schneider da oben der bäder gmbh
th annual
[Musik]
es wird
immer lauter
aha keiner hat mich geglaubt aber jetzt
zeige ich seine eltern da das war das
ist ja 34 jahren mama ich habe den
laacher see gefunden von dem flug
arbeitet hat man ihn direkt finden wir
der bad tatsächlich direkt daneben wo
ich mich runter gegraben hat also ich
habe gar nicht so viel pech aber ich
habe ihn einfach nicht ich gehe ich
jetzt hier ist kein diamant jetzt
absolut hier ist hier ist kein einziger
kein einziger diamant ich luke an
anderer stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wie bereits gesagt hat moritz
auf die idee gebracht meinte einfach ein
luca ich habe letztens ein erstes video
vorgeschlagen bekommen jetzt die das
ganze mal nachstellt ich habs jetzt
nicht richtig nachgestellt von wegen ich
spreche jeden satz nach weil ich doch
dass wir ein bisschen langweilig
geworden sondern ich wollte einfach ein
bisschen diese anleitung befolgen und
gucken ob es noch klappt und es hat
ewige bereits gesehen habt echt grandios
geklappt wenn ich das heute wieder
gefallen da würde ich mich auf jeden
fall sehr sehr dünne war einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video hier
freunde schreibt mir auch mal gerne in
die kommentare
seit wann ihr abonnent zeit von meinem
kanal das wird mich auch mal
interessieren gibt es wirklich leute die
mich nach diesem minecraft in unter fünf
minuten video abonniert habe und jetzt
immer noch meine videos schauen dass wir
auf jeden fall mega witzig abonniert auf
jeden fall zu dem auch gern meinen kanal
falls noch keinen teil der luxus ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
und der letzte satz gehört dir luca von
vor acht jahren ich hoffe ihr habt euch
das video angeschaut
[Musik]